Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Both of us!
Thank you so much for waking up early and joining us today for our 99th episode!
99!
Can you believe it?
The last episode of FUWAMOCO Morning with two numbers beside it.
Are you sad, Ruffians?
We have one more before 100!
That's how it works, right?
Numbers, huh?
BAU BAU!
Your two numbers is over.
A little bit lonely, but you cried a little!
Don't worry!
It's still early for that!
But that means we'll be getting a new number for next time, right?
Is that how it works?
I numbers friends.
Not my friends.
BAU BAU!
Well, for any Ruffians joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
AKA FUWAMOCO!
That's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
FWMCMORNING.
Moco-chan, where'd the second hashtag go?
I didn't see hashtag, hashtag denied!
See it, Moco-chan!
See it!
Is it necessary?
You really want it.
Please!
Pretty please!
It's necessary!
Necessary!
You have to say pretty please, Ruffians!
Pretty please!
Ruffians!
If you put it that nicely then.
Hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
Hashtag hashtag.
BAU BAU!
Wow, I didn't expect that kind of reaction, huh?
That's more like it!
Ruffians still saying pretty please!
If you ask Ruffians to say pretty please, they'll continue saying it for a very long time.
Your day is made!
Well, I'm just about to ruin it.
Guys, there's been another peron sighting.
You know, recently it's been pretty bad.
Pero's been seen in a bunch of places.
Yeah.
What place has he been seen now?
Well, let's take a look.
De-den!
Oh no.
Did Pero sneak into your PC and cause problems?
Ruffians, have you been having any computer troubles?
Has it been slow and mild?
You know, maybe you should open it up and check things out.
Otherwise, a big blob with ears and wings could have installed himself without you knowing.
Pero Sensor.
Pero Peace.
Ruffians!
I'm pretty sure there's been more than a few Ruffians with this issue though before, right, Moco-chan?
I think I saw some, hi.
Ruffians, you need to make sure that you keep yourself and your computer safe, okay?
You're one to speak, hi!
You need to stay safe, okay?
Not wearing a virus.
Yeah.
But your computer is not an appropriate place for Pero to be staying in.
And you know what?
He'll stay there forever if he thinks he can get away with it.
He will.
Yeah.
You wouldn't want that, huh?
No.
Ruffians, you know, if your computer, if it's slowing down and there are loud sounds from it, especially if it's like a really nasty loud.
Gotta check it out right away, okay?
Yeah, okay.
Can't put it off, okay?
You have to be proactive.
Peroactive.
Okay, Moco-chan.
Proactive!
Pero.
BAU BAU!
Okay, Moco-chan.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Congratulations Sora-senpai!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
We're so excited!
Yeah!
Did you hear about the opening?
It's huge!
Yeah, and the anime!
It's called My Wife Has No Emotion.
And the song is called Okaerinasai.
So cute!
And I am so excited!
Yeah, yeah!
Not just because you know Sora-senpai sang the opening theme song.
Very exciting, very exciting!
It's because...
There's Mii Robots.
And I love Mii Robots!
Especially when they fall in love.
So I'll definitely be watching this anime.
It starts airing at the beginning of next month.
So soon.
Right soon!
It sounds so cute!
And I will probably cry a bunch.
You can actually already check out the song as well!
Yeah!
Check out Tokinosora-senpai on Twitter!
She has a whole bunch more information about it here.
Here we have a comment left.
BAU BAU!
One day!
We can sing anime opening songs here!
One day.
One day maybe.
Yeah, not today.
Not tomorrow.
One day.
Maybe!
Yeah, you know, both Kyary-senpai and Sora-senpai sing anime songs now!
So amazing!
We have such amazing senpai FUWAMOCO-chan!
BAU BAU!
Congratulations!
FUWAMOCO!
Well, speaking of Ai-senpai, you know, there's been some exciting new looks being supported by our EN-senpai!
So, and you know, like, the seasons are changing and fashion, fashion kind of changes along with the seasons.
So we thought that, you know, with the beginning of summer here, that we could, like, a bit of a look at them!
Yeah!
Yeah, first,
We have Kiara-senpai!
She has her new, brand new, 80's exercise style outfit!
It's so cute!
Right?
Thanks for waiting!
Yeah, it's got some, uh, breathing holes on the sleeves there.
I sort of have that for my New Year's outfit.
A little bit, right?
You know, maybe it's not quite an 80s thing, but it's always fun to do exercise videos on YouTube, right?
It's sort of the same feel, right?
Yeah, maybe Kiara-senpai, maybe she'll release some cool exercise videos to do together with the KFP!
Yeah!
Right!
Fuwawa-boshi, what?
Excuse me.
I like to be able to focus on my exercising.
And you know, um, if, if I, if I'm a bit exposed then, uh... Where the FUWAMOCO going?!
What?
There's also, Moco-chan, I know, what about Mococo is what you're saying, but what about Kronii-senpai?
Right?
Recently Kronii-senpai also got a new outfit too!
Super cool and controlling commanding Kronii!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning was a big one!
Bae-senpai also got a brand new outfit!
It's a very chuny chaos red sleeve.
She has an eye patch too, Moco-chan!
Yeah, bunnies!
Yeah, but both her and Kronii-senpai kind of look like they could whip you into shape, right?
But, couldn't Kiara-senpai also whip you into shape, too?
I guess... A different kind of whip you into shape, girl!
Yeah, we're gonna whip you into shape, huh?
Yeah, you better listen to what we have to say, huh?
Yeah... What do you think, Ruffians?
If FUWAMOCO is to get new outfits,
What do you think are the best?
Maybe cool outfits like these?
Or do you think they would suit us?
Or wear something more cute and comfy?
Yeah.
That would be better.
Huh?
Sleeves!
Do we not have enough sleeves for you now?
Sure, sure!
Bikinis!
Ruffians!
What are you two wearing now?
Astronaut outfits!
Like Ame-senpai!
So cute!
Princess outfits!
Comfy.
Combat.
Bikini.
Swimsuit.
Pajamas.
Bikini.
Swimsuit.
Pajamas.
BAU BAU!
I like pajamas.
Fluffy and fuzzy pajamas for the fluffy and fuzzy ones, you know?
It's always good.
Always good.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, maybe you know you've been a little bit busy and haven't really noticed, but FUWAMOCO, we've been undergoing some very serious training.
Yeah.
Training.
In Minecraft!
Yeah!
You know, it might be hard to believe, but... FUWAMOCO!
We really don't know much about Minecraft.
We don't really have had any experience with it until we joined hololive.
Right!
No experience.
We never played it.
No.
So, now we're trying our best to learn the basics.
Yeah!
Along with your very much appreciated help, obviously.
Unnecessary help.
Yeah.
You know, and so far we've learned how to survive night time.
Night time was very scary.
Yeah.
I made a bazillion stone pickaxes all at once.
And we caught sheep.
And finally, we're starting to be able to make and eat food.
Amongst a bunch of other things.
It's a very comfy time.
You know, we're dual streaming it.
So that means it's Fuwawa POV and my POV.
Yeah.
So you know, you can check maybe Moco-chan out as she minds and Fuwawa as I make food.
I'm still not sure how food works though.
Cause Moco-chan, your tummy killed you, right?
I think so, yeah.
I thought someone was shooting at me, but no.
I don't know how it works.
Why does it have two food bars?
You just eat it, that's all.
We'll have to find out next time.
But because we're both streaming at the same time, you can hear both of us in the background, we can chat amongst each other.
I think it makes a kind of a unique experience, a bit of a different kind of Minecraft.
Ruffians, but!
We're gonna be doing our best to continue our training weekly!
So please join us this weekend for a nice, relaxing... Yeah.
Just Minecraft time together.
Minecraft time teaches common sense.
Please, please.
Okay, backseating is okay, okay.
Please, please help, okay.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, it's a big learning experience, yeah.
Thank you for all the help, Ruffians!
Thank you!
FUWAMOCO Minecraft.
BAU BAU!
Well, as I said, you know, Ruffians, right now, it's the summer of Advent within the year of FUWAMOCO!
You know, that means that FUWAMOCO, we're gonna be zooming around!
You know, not only have zoomies,
This summer time, yeah.
Tired and slow zoomies.
But not only will we just be at New York City for the hololive English second month of Breaking Dimensions, but we'll also be in Australia for Smash!
Bye!
Are we gonna be playing Minecraft in Australia?
No, we're not playing Minecraft in Australia!
That would be exciting though.
I'm sure there's a lot of things like creepers and fuzzy mistakes.
You know those kind of Minecraft enemies, the purple guy?
Probably in Australia too, right?
That makes sense.
Yeah.
But it'll be our first time down under high!
Yeah!
We're working hard to prepare for it.
Right now!
Through Smash's SNS, you can send them a question.
You'd like to have us answer at the event too?
Yeah.
Alright, so if there's any Ruffians planning on going, please send Smash your questions and we'll answer them there for you.
And you know, maybe there's some silly Ruffians out there.
You might ask a question too, but you won't be at the event.
Ruffians!
Do you know what you can do to get your question answered even if you won't be going to Australia?
You know, right?
Oh my gosh, I don't think they know, Moco-chan.
We say it every time.
We say it every time, Ruffians!
Yeah!
Hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Okay, Ruffians, no pouting, okay?
I think you're distracted by the hashtag hashtag!
They don't know what the hashtag is for!
Moco-chan, you gotta cut that out then, okay?
And also, the lottery for our meet and greet tickets will be opening soon, okay?
They'll be opening at 8am Australia time on the 20th this month.
So any Australian Ruffians who'd like to chat with us, please mark it into your calendars, okay?
8am, bright and early, down under.
You know, we think we'll be able to talk with more Ruffians this time compared to our first meet-and-greet in Taipei.
Right!
We're so excited to talk to you face-to-face, Ruffians!
Please show us your biggest smiles, okay?
Got it!
BAU BAU!
We're excited!
It'll definitely be a super fun time.
Yeah.
Wow.
There's some exciting things.
No, it's also not exciting, Ruffians.
When you make a mistake.
Yeah.
And, uh, Fuwawa, uh, I have some bad news.
Yeah?
You know, the other day when we were out with Nerissa, we actually brought some new pajamas together!
Did Nerissa give you pajamas?
No.
FUWAMOCO we bought pajamas.
She was with us.
We counted together.
And she bought pajamas from the same place.
Pajamas are really fluffy and fuzzy and luxurious.
Yeah.
Actually, FUWAMOCO, we'd really like to have a collaboration with them one day.
Yeah!
You know, because we're fluffy and fuzzy.
But, uh... Cute pajamas, you know?
Yeah.
Cuter than this!
But, uh, so the new pajamas, I decided to wear them for the first time this morning.
And you know, Ruffians, whenever you get something that's brand new, you're always very careful not to get it dirty or hurt.
Right!
So, I was very very careful until you know, I got a bit too excited while I was drinking my matcha latte.
And uh, I ended up missing my mouth and accidentally poured it down the front of my pajamas.
I was like, to Moco-chan, Moco-chan, help!
Tissues, tissues!
But we're all out of tissues!
There was a lot of latte everywhere!
So Moco-chan was just like, take it off, Moco-chan!
So I took it off and I quickly rinsed it with cold water.
I think I got a lot of the matcha off, but...
We'll see how it is after it's done with the wash.
Yeah.
It was a really horrible steam bath, Moco-chan.
It was bad.
But luckily we have steam remover because I... This is not a rare occurrence.
Yeah.
I accidentally... What?
I accidentally sprayed something on Moco-chan the other day which stained your shirt.
Yeah.
It just happened.
But, uh, yeah.
I don't know.
I can't believe I was that clumsy.
I just missed my mouth.
Again.
But my mouth tattoo... If it's no good, we'll just have to hope that we can get some more cute pajamas soon.
Right, Moco-chan?
Hopefully.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, I'm gonna try not to miss my mouth again.
Do your best.
Yeah.
Well, Ruffians!
And that means today we get to see another Doggie of the Day!
Does it have to do with the end of the week?
I don't know, I just know Doggie of the Day, Doggie of the Day.
I'm excited for the Doggie of the Day.
Hi!
This is the Doggie of the Day today, Moco-chan!
We have a de-den!
Akami!
Alchemy!
Really fitting name, huh?
Right!
Look at the powerful eyes and- Right!
Is that a coffee cup?
I think so, you know.
Cuz you know Alchemy!
Alchemy is a wolf hybrid!
Huh!
Actually, doggy looks wow, really cool, right?
Really cool!
Just a big goofball!
Love his, like, eyes.
Looks cool!
Big goofball, huh?
I don't know if we have the looks cool part down, but...
I don't exactly like Alchemy, no.
Alchemy also likes to have fun and cuddle, and as seen here, likes to collect objects while on walks.
You know, maybe Alchemy is going to use them for us.
Maybe.
Don't know what's in the cup.
Right.
How does Alchemy BAU BAU, Moco-chan?
Alchemy looks cool, but... But?
I think the BAU BAU is like... BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Really?
I disagree.
It's like... BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Like that.
Really?
Yeah!
No.
You disagree, right, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
Why?
Alchemy looks wise as the name suggests, you know?
But...
Pretty silly, just like FUWAMOCO!
Right?
It must be nice looking all serious though.
You know, if Akuma goes extreme violence, you're gonna run away.
Hi!
Just like us, too!
BAU BAU!
How come he's so cool?
I'm cool, though.
BAU BAU!
And next, Ruffians!
Show us where you've been going on a walk, huh?
Let's take a walk!
We have de-den!
What?
Oh!
A boulder field!
A camping trip!
So when someone is like, I want a boulder!
Is this where they go?
Get them from?
Like a rock store.
Oh, but a field!
Kind of like a pumpkin field, but with boulders, right?
Right!
They have pebbles a little bit bigger than pebbles.
Bee-boo land!
You went on a camping trip to bee-boo land!
Rock, rock!
This is the pebbles' birthplace!
But this looks so cool!
I'm sure it's really hard to walk across the... Every time you step on the pebbles, it... Bleh!
We're very glad you did what you saw.
And I hope you had an amazing camping trip too.
BAU BAU!
And our Question of the Day we have... De-den!
Good morning, Fuwawa-chan!
Good morning, Moco-chan!
Good morning!
If you were to take out each advent member to a two-on-one or even one-on-one date, where would you take each of them on one date?
I think this is an easy question.
Right, Moco-chan?
There's so many places I want to go with them.
Shiori!
Read to some kind of place that's very unique to Japan.
Maybe somewhere more with subculture.
And more books that she wants.
Yeah.
I think she's been saying she wants to go find more books.
Now there's a lot of places I can think of.
Ah, for Nerissa!
Some place that's like classy and has a meet.
Has a meet.
Yeah.
So some place you know that is kind of like Japan, but classy.
With a meet.
Yeah.
And then, Biboo!
Somewhere maybe more fun, and like, younger, hip.
Hip!
Maybe somewhere that has games, like a theme park or something.
Yeah.
You know, Dagashiya-san.
Right.
That would be fun.
Problem is, it'd be fun with all of them.
Yeah, I'd like to take all of Advent to Dagashiya-san.
Yeah, you know, like a Japanese candy store.
Right?
Sweet store.
There's just so many places and such a long list of things we want to do together with Advent.
But I don't know if we have enough time this time.
It's tricky trying to get everybody's schedules to line up, you know?
Yeah.
So, you know, we might only be able to do so much together this time.
But we'll treasure the moments that we do have to share together.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, so many places.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you so much!
So, so much for 99 episodes of your submissions of spending all these mornings together.
But Ruffians, I want to remind you, just because we're about to reach 100 episodes doesn't mean you get to stop submitting your doggy of the days, your walks,
Your questions, your Pero Sightings, okay?
Doesn't mean that you get to stop.
We're always looking for new submissions, so please remember, use the hashtag!
F-W-M-C-MORNING!
Okay.
Yeah.
If you say hashtag, hashtag, they're not gonna focus, right?
No.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Well, we have a new stream coming up very soon, right, Moco-chan?
Yeah!
Our next stream is...
Mbembe Radio.
Yeah, Mbembe Radio.
It's a horror adventure game where, you know, we kind of explore things on the way back home from school.
And then we kind of notice some strange occurrences happening.
I have no clue about it.
It's something sort of obscure and there's an Mbembe Radio!
Mbembe... What's an Mbembe?
BAU BAU!
And then, on Sunday, we're gonna be having a watch-along of "Hachi: a Dog's Tale" together with our Doggy Pack!
I'm looking forward to it.
Just a nice time watching a movie all together.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
And for any Ruffians who are joining us through the archives today, here is your FUWAMOCODE word!
It's... BAU BAU!
Hope.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU HOPE!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Well, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Coco Puffs!
BAU BAU!
Anaya.
Marina.
BAU BAU!
Shirahoshi.
Starsama.
BAU BAU!
Pipo.
Tanaka.
BAU BAU!
Mikule.
Daima.
BAU BAU!
Apollo!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!